[Music]
well guys I'd like to start and this is
not just because the cameras rolling and
we're all framed up this was so good you
guys were both fantastic I thoroughly
and completely enjoyed this film
congratulations thank you
you know there was a little eyes on this
franchise of course you know a little
bit of first what was it like for you
guys being in that theater I saw you
down there getting all the applause
everybody's so excited watching it
listening to them what was that
experience like I mean as far as like
specific fan encounters or memorable
moments interacting with the fans now
that they really know that you guys are
involved in this it was an l-3 cosplay
guy on the red carpet which is cool he'd
become dressed as l-3 yeah it's good
yeah it's just always amazing to me how
much the fans can quickly put together
their own costume just even like in the
theater when we walked in yeah as a
Lando he just stood up he was like but I
was like you're dressed like new Lando
like dressed like to do that it's like
it's a lot of hard work it's unfamiliar
a lot of commitments like you know the
love for the love the love is really
unparalleled u2 piloting the Millennium
Falcon is I mean does it get any better
than that
really was it take take us through that
first time you're sitting in our seats
and and going through the motions there
well we were given a little bit of time
they showed us the cockpit first cuz I
think we're all gonna go a bit weird
it's like borderline tears just wanting
to press every button and then let me
were kind of just in the seats for like
half a day and you know I just got used
to it as crazy as that sounds no you
don't really get used to it
like you're always in the Millennium
Falcon I mean like it's just like you
know it's a tight squeeze so like
there's a lot of like maneuvering and
going
but you never especially with like chewy
like with a wookie next to you yeah you
always keep remembering like oh I'm in
I'm in Star Wars right I'm well I'm like
in the Millennium felt like that that
was very strange he's a constant
reminder in the evidence there's the
second that you might be forgetting you
be like screen around the around all the
front windows in the cockpit so that
we've actually felt like we were in
space when we were taking off and we
would push the lever the hydraulics
would move it was basically like it like
a Disney rider so yeah it was just like
you get a little bit nervous I have I
have a feeling that's coming like that
maybe some sort of oh yeah
so funny moments ago we had Alden in
here and he was surprised by the man the
og han Solo
Harrison Ford came in here in surprise
have you guys had a chance to meet
Harrison no no no he's saying that he's
like Superman like it was like we you
just you just you are you Harrison Ford
you can tell us
are you alright well you did dog you say
you're friendly and you hang out a
little bit with Billy Dee Williams you
guys text all the time you saw each
other at the premiere had you I don't
want to say we text though that's I
don't have to be like text at the
premiere I guess wanna know what was
this reaction his feedback from seeing
the film he said he was gonna let you
know he did he said good job like that
was all I was like it was really good
like doesn't say but he played it cool
he played it cool just like it he was
like great job man and I was like I was
like man like he didn't even have to do
that like that's the thing I was like it
would have been I'm just glad that he
got to see it you know
probably yeah he texted me afterwards
and just told me about it that's pretty
cool
that must have been a good text again
sure we'll have to ask about you working
on this film motion capture motion
capture suit I'm assuming all the time
what was that like for you it was great
because it was half a practical suit and
a half a motion capture oh so I still
had the kind of the the most cumbersome
bits of the of the droid costume on me
it's really helped kind of define the
character and then I could kind of
lumber around I mean I was just like a
green it was just an inner green sock
with you know kind of like I've been
rolled in metal all right a green sauce
it rolled in metal yeah that's always
what I thought what was it like acting
opposite that I mean it was actually
quite natural like I mean it was a it
didn't feel weird
the hard part was that like you know she
had this like you know the l3 head is on
her head so you should be wanting to
talk to Phoebe and she's like look me in
the eye
oh yeah yeah yeah like you know but
everything else was actually like it was
really cool liked and she was really I'm
saying this yesterday like there's
almost like a puppetry in it because
she'd do a lot of like head thing and
stuff like with her fingers and stuff
and it felt really cool like I I it was
easy to pretend because they keep you
did a really good job of just being a
robot anytime I go wait is when I
actually took my like mas new you know
the new l3 it's just green face let me
ask yes what kind of music do you think
l3 and Lando would be into probably jizz
roaches like that's the like the space
form of jazz that since that's it's an
official thing it's called chase no no
yeah no it's go just go back to Falcon
fill it up with Jay Taylor which is and
just
like ears just think would they be in to
Childish Gambino she'd be quite critical
but then she'd be like just privately
listening to audio situation yeah I get
that I got to tell you we're over Eddie
T super psyched about Lion King coming
up you're a Simba opposite Beyonce's now
have you guys started rehearsing for
that yet I mean yeah we we started
recording some stuff it's like dating
from my my point of view but like I mean
it's it's probably the safest thing just
cause like I mean everybody who's
involved it's a lot like this in ways
which is like everybody who's involved
as a fan right everybody who's involved
like knows really well like they're like
so hear the lyrics I'm like don't worry
like I was in fourth grade this came out
like oh yeah so it's it's actually been
really great and just hearing her do it
it's been like man this is it's really
it's a really special thing how are they
actually do I you guys in motion capture
or partially like how does that work no
it's like um I think more Jungle Book
thinking more like Jungle Book we're
like it's I don't know it's beautiful
looking it's like the part I mean like
it's not obviously done yet you know wow
you know it did you did people see like
the the trailer that they played at like
d23 people like I think it's online okay
I was on the Carm I didn't get to see
the trailer like it's like that watch
the trailer it is incredible it's like
watching Planet Earth
you must be touching yourself these days
man I mean yeah I mean no I got ya I got
kids who keep me right down there oh
yeah just like oh this is amazing just
wiping poop on so long as you're
stocking up as a dad though I mean being
part of some of these projects they
don't care yet like they're too young to
begin
a crap Lego vile like any of it like
they're just like yeah like whatever
like even you can be like Landa this is
daddy and he's like okay cool dad he's
on a horse now whatever like he doesn't
really it doesn't affect anything yet
all right well you guys congratulations
I got to wrap things up it's I really
love the film I love the whole bunch of
stuff you guys got going on so thanks
for taking the time thank you guys
[Music]